and joining us now is counselor to the
president Kellyanne Conway
good evening Kellyanne hi Janine all
right talk to us about the president and
what you expect him to do tomorrow I
understand he's visiting both Texas and
Louisiana with the first lady that's
right the president the first lady will
return to Texas and as Louisiana to the
schedule tomorrow really to meet with
the storm survivors the evacuees the
rescuers the volunteers and to also
coordinate even more with local state
officials get some briefings from them
you know the federal government has
29,000 of its employees on the ground in
the affected areas 1,000 from Health and
Human Services alone and people from HUD
from small business administration
transportation EPA you name it it's been
a full administration cabinet wide
presidential vice presidential effort
and the president the first lady want
people in Texas and Louisiana to know
that a grateful nation applause those
who are volunteering stranger to
stranger neighbor to neighbor as
continuing to rescue and they also the
president also wants to convey to the
country at the convey on behalf of the
country that we will stand with our
brothers and sisters in Texas in
Louisiana for as long as we as long as
the recovering the rebuilding takes and
nobody really Jeanine can look around
the corner and predict that as you've
been getting all these briefings we full
well know a housing is an issue food
shelter water certainly medical and
dental care related to the storm any
type of other emergency people are
having transportation wise we know that
people have lost their property their
personal effects and and worse their
loved one will leave stand with them and
the president will continue to
coordinate we were so impressed with the
governor's with the local and state
officials with the volunteers everything
that's happened really administration
wise FEMA DHS they've just been
incredible well they have been and I
know I was in a flood my family we lost
our house was condemned years ago to
incur akane agnes and you don't realize
how important government assistance is
for things as simple as clothing because
you've lost everything
and food try and I was just talking to
dr. Segal about bringing in supplies and
water and you know the good thing that
we're hearing is that the president and
the first lady in the first week of this
hurricane Harvey will have visited the
storm area twice and you know when you
look back at another administration of
Republican administration with President
Bush it took them 14 days to show up and
you know for all those critics of the
President and I've had enough and I'm
sure you have too about milania's shoes
or should the president of hug someone
are not on someone the good news is that
the facts speak for themselves
the country should see what is in that
their hearts and not what's on their
feet and most people can cut through
that that peevish pettiness and and that
all aside the Trump's also have donated
1 million dollars and they're
encouraging everyone else who feels like
they can help in any way whether you are
on the ground helping those who are
affected you can donate some money
donate blood help get people the
information they need I think that's one
of the greatest resources that the media
can provide right now is connecting
people with the information they need
how to access a disaster relief how to
access transportation fresh water as
you're saying this is something you can
do no matter where you are across the
country and the White House continues to
also be a great resource in connecting
people with websites and links with
1-800 numbers if you have access to a
working telephone but but again the
president today even just today
declaring calling for Sunday to be a
National Day of Prayer really in honor
of those in memory of those who have
lost their lives in honor of those who
are rebuilding their lives now all those
who have been part of the rescue of
recovery efforts as well and continue to
be part of the recovery of your building
relief efforts um he also today got a
briefing from the American Red Cross
from the Southern Baptist disaster
really works and certainly Salvation
Army I'm thanking them but also hearing
from them that's that the important part
here ok we don't we into a great listen
I've been listening this one I'm running
up against a break but I think that one
of the overarching themes here is that
we're seeing people come together we're
seeing the president actually on the
ground and we're seeing people in Texas
and I know a lot of people in Texas
coming together not saying help me poor
me I can't help myself but they're out
there doing it getting it done moving
back into their homes accessing and
helping each other black and white young
and old and it really is a positive
story about this country starting at the
top and where we're going to come out as
it relates to this administration you're
looking at the best of America right in
front of our eyes and we applaud
everyone nobody cares what their
politics are right if they supported the
president last election or even
registered to vote were there to help
each other and this is the president on
November 9th Janeane right after he was
declared the victor he said I would be
the president of all Americans including
those who did not support me and this is
this is the latest proof of that you two
days on the job as campaign manager he
and governor pence went to Baton Rouge a
year ago President Obama is on Martha's
Vineyard Hillary Clinton do not go down
to Baton Rouge they went down there and
they helped people we all saw the images
of coffins floating away in people in
need as mr. Trump and governor pence
went on there to Baton Rouge and they
did it again this week which he knows
he's got the capacity to help people he
does it Kellyanne
thanks so much for being with us tonight
and thanks for having me